So, there's a lot of trends
in the Silicon Valley.
Should I, as an entrepreneur,
look for an idea around the trend?
>> Again, I think it depends.
There's a lot of people who can be very,
kind of like, trans centric.
Social mobile local is hard,
so let's all go chase that.
Or, everybody wants to,
I don't know how many companies have
heard about shared economy, you know?
Back in 2000s,
there was this wave about pets.
So, I think that there's a lot of this,
I hate to use the word herd mentality,
everybody wants to go do the same thing.
But, having said that, I think it's
valuable to look at current disruptions,
current dislocations,
like for example, mobile.
Having a camera on the mobile phone, or
having your location
on the mobile phone.
It's created businesses around
like Uber or Instagram.
These are really mobile first companies.
And this wasn't possible,
six, seven, eight years ago.
So, I think studying, hey there is this
big movement from landlines to mobile.
I think, people can consciously think
about down screen impacts of those
things, and
businesses then can then be created.
Music is another great example.
Music has been massively disrupted,
around how you produce it,
how do you distribute it,
and all of that.
Companies like Spotify, or even device
makers, iPods and phones, and so on.
So, I think there's a lot of benefit
in thinking about disruptions,
and what does that mean three years
from now, six years from now.
A cloud is a great example.
All right.
AWSI are doing cloud, and now there
are numerous companies that got
created around that trend,
security, payments, and so on.
So, I think it's valuable, but
having said that, I don't want to just
recommend that as the only approach.
We can see companies that are created
in retail, in agriculture,
in insurance, in data, and so on.
So, just old-fashioned industries
that people are not looking at.
But, there's a lot of opportunity,
because incumbents populate those,
and it's not the sexy thing to do.
But you can definitely
create businesses there.
>> So, as an entrepreneur,
how should I think about competition,
and how should it impact my product?
>> I think it's very important
to be aware of the competition.
But, I think it also depends
on the state of the company.
I've seen entrepreneurs
that get very distracted
by trying to follow and
copy every move off their competition.
I think it's not very healthy.
Especially, if you're trying
to go after a new market,
if you're creating a new category.
You let somebody else define
your moves and your product.
And that's not healthy.
But, I think as you start maturing,
and as you start optimizing
it's useful to think about even
small differences in the product
can create massive differences
in the mindset of consumers.
So, I think if I were to simplify,
if you're just getting going,
if you're in a new category,
don't let the competition define you.
But if you're mature,
I think you need to pay more
attention to the competition.